on les aime démoniser depuis l'hiver
dernier
et pourtant les virus pourrait être très
utile en élevage pour combattre
certaines bactéries et éviter l' usage
les antibiotiques
imaginez un instant que chercheurs
arrivent à trouver une partie de la
solution à la résistance aux
antibiotiques dans un ruisseau près d'un
poulailler science fiction peut-être pas
[Musique]
vous avez sous les yeux la plus ancienne
des gars sur terre une guerre vieille de
4 milliards d'années
ce virus est en pleine attaque contre
une bactérie
il la transperce pour en prendre le
contrôle et se multiplier cette
catégorie de virus qui s'attaque
uniquement aux bactéries
ce sont les bactériophages les grands
régulateurs de bactéries sur terre
sans ces virus qu'on appelle aussi
d'eiffage les maladies causées par la
bactérie e coli ou la salmonelle par
exemple seraient légion
autant chez les humains que chez les
animaux et si on utilisait les phages
pour régler le problème numéro un en
élevage la sur utilisation des
antibiotiques
ces poussins donc dix jours
mais certaines portent déjà en une
souche de bactérie e.coli une souche qui
leur sera mortel la majorité des
infections bactériennes chez les
poussins séduit e coli la bactérie
e.coli c'est une des grandes causes
utilisation des antibiotiques en élevage
avicole en 2019
on a interdit certains antibiotiques
qu'on administré à titre préventif
les producteurs ont tous sitôt
enregistré une hausse des mortalités
c'est sûr que si on a produit 6
incroyable mais ce minuscule filet d'eau
contient peut-être la solution à ce
problème
nous sommes en beauce près de québec
à quelques pas d'un poulailler le
chercheur simon l'abri est convaincu que
cette eau renferme la solution à
plusieurs maladies bactériennes de même
qu'à la surutilisation d'antibiotiques
on est dans un environnement rural c'est
ce qu'on a décidé de venir
échantillonnés si c'est notre terrain de
jeu
ces plantages en fait dans cette
bouteille d'eau lors le plus de la caf h
que d'humains sur la taille et la
diversité aussi on dirait pas seulement
car il y en a des milliers
surgit différentes nous on veut quelque
chose de précis qui est vraiment adapté
au milieu agricole
c'est pour ça qu'on est venu
sélectionner les souches de
bactériophages qui nous intéresse dans
un milieu comme ça
simon l'abri dirige l'une des rares
entreprises à travailler sur les
bactériophages il veut développer une
arme biologique contre les pathogènes en
élevage les à solution est prometteuse
son équipe vient tout juste d'isoler
parmi des milliers de fans ceux qui
s'attaquent uniquement aux souches
problématique de la peau colis
pour isoler les bons fages l'équipe à
user d'astuces
[Musique]
les chercheurs ont d'abord recueilli les
souches de colis reconnu comme pathogène
auprès du ministère de l'agriculture
[Musique]
ils ont ensuite multiplié ses e coli
pour qu'elle devienne de la nourriture à
bactériophages
c'est ici qu'entre en scène les phages
issus du ruisseau agricole cette goutte
d'eau en compte y ait des milliers de
souche différente
aussitôt déposé sur les colis les
hostilités débutent
seuls les virus adapté à détruire les
colis vont survivre et se multiplier moi
ce que j'ai fait là j'ai mis des
bactéries partout sur le milieu de
culture puis ensuite j'ai déposé une
goutte de l'échantillon qui contient les
bactériophages qu'on veut aller plus à
partir de ce moment alors la bactérie
pousse le bac terrière file un fake est
suspecté et là on est capable d'avoir
une zone d'émission la croissance
bactérienne
le résultat est en effet visible à
l'oeil nu
chacun des ces cercles et le reste d'un
champ de bataille
ça veut dire que les bactéries ont été
tués et quand on a la multiplication des
partis de quelques virus et on est rendu
avec des millions de livres seront pas
environ 2 1 millions à 10 millions de
virus partie plage clair au final le
chercheur a en main uniquement les
phages d'intérêt ce qui anéantissent les
colis présent en élevage
[Musique]
simon l'abri est issu d'un des
laboratoires les plus reconnus sur les
bactériophages celui du chercheur
s'élevait moine ou de l'université laval
ce spécialiste est convaincu que les
phages pourront un jour prévenir
certaines maladies infectieuses et s'ils
remplaçaient bien des antibiotiques
ce qui s'est produit avec les
antibiotiques malheureusement c'est
qu'on s'est mis à les utiliser à
profusion dans plusieurs applications
particulièrement dans le domaine
agricole et s'amener à ses sept
développement de résistances aux
antibiotiques donc c'est clair qu'un
mouvement international pour réduire
l'utilisation des antibiotiques pour que
ceux ci soient vraiment utilisé à bon
escient c'est à dire dans l'endroit où
on en a vraiment besoin c'est à dire
pour traiter les gens ou pour traiter
des animaux l'avantagent avec les phages
c'est qu'il tue les bactéries pathogènes
mais contrairement aux antibiotiques ils
épargnent celle dont l'organisme a
besoin
les antibiotiques ont un très large
spectre ans donc les antibiotiques vont
tuer plusieurs bactéries
ça va avoir un impact sur notre
microbiote le microbiote des animaux
bien entendu alors que l'on quand on
parle des bactériophages on veut
vraiment ciblé une bactérie ou un groupe
de bach et donc la notion de spécificité
est extrêmement importante
mais pour passer du laboratoire à la
ferme
il fallait trouver une façon
d'administrer les phages au boulet les
bactériophages sont partout dans
l'environnement
il y aurait dix fois plus de femmes que
de bactéries sur la planète comme il
constitue l'entité biologique la plus
abondante sur terre les phages colonise
l'intestin de ces volailles
tout comme d'ailleurs celui des humains
ils cohabitent dans le poulet avec le
colis mais les problèmes surviennent
quand cette bactérie pathogène prend le
dessus
c'est à ce moment que le poulet a besoin
de renforts l'équipe de simon labrie a
eu l'idée d'incorporer les phages
directement de la moule et des poussins
cette poudre est le résultat d'années
d'études elle contient en fait plusieurs
phases qui ont été isolés puis
déshydraté afin d'être mélangés à la
mouline on sera pas capable de faire
produit qui va durer dans le temps puis
qu'ils voient est efficace contre des
souches qu'on retrouve au québec qu'on
retrouve en ontario ou qu'on retrouve
aux états unis nous ce qu'on veut c'est
un produit qui couvrent un éventail de
souche bactérienne large pour ce que
souvent dans le domaine des thérapies
ont reparlé de cocktails bactériophages
pour commercialiser ce nouveau produit
il faut que les poussins ingurgite les
phages des leurs tout premiers jours de
vie hors de 0 à 4 jours les poussins ne
mange que très peu de mouler
pour contourner ce problème on tue la
menace dans l'oeuf
c'est eux vont éclore dans quelques
jours
avant que la réglementation ne
l'interdise en 2019
c'était des antibiotiques qu'on injectés
dans ces coquilles pour lutter contre le
colis en ce moment c'est une micro doses
de phage qu'on injecte dans l'embryon
comme la grèce mais au lieu que ce soit
renversé compin virus non rexel donc une
bactérie puis on vaccine 1,5 pour qu'ils
deviennent miser contre leur camp dit
salah protège de 0 à 4
oh
les phages s'avère une arme biologique
redoutable
les tests effectués dans de petits
élevages expérimentaux ont été couronnés
de succès
reste maintenant à les tester dans les
immenses élevage du québec et de
l'ontario
le marché est colossal on produit
annuellement plus de 1 milliards de
kilos de poulet par année au canada aux
états unis
c'est 20 fois plus les phages pourraient
être utiles pour bien d'autres maladies
[Musique]
à l'université laval
sylvain moineau gère la plus importante
collection de phage au monde c'est
frigon enferme d'eiffage capable de
lutter conte centre en espèces de
bactéries différentes
aujourd'hui on a déjà des bactériophages
sont efficaces contre les souches d'un
colis qui nous intéresse on a déjà des
bactériophages sont efficaces contre les
salmonelles qui nous intéresse
maintenant le défi si on les applique
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
l'environnement
donc est-ce que les bactéries vont
devenir résistantes à ces bactériophages
il est là le grand défi en utilisant les
phages à large échelle
on pourrait favoriser l'apparition d'une
résistance
[Musique]
simon l'abri est bien au fait de ce
problème mais ennemis sur
l'extraordinaire capacité d'adaptation
d'eiffage pour déjouer les défenses des
bactéries on appelle ça la course à
l'armement à chaque fois qu'une bactérie
résistante
il ya un bacteria page qui vous devenez
résultat la bactérie qui résiste en est
si tu es donc c'est vraiment une course
à l'évolution est constante depuis des
milliards d'années
nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on accélère
cette course là pour faire gagner les
bactériophages à terme cela pourrait
signifier qu'il faudra parfois retourné
au terrain pour sélectionner un nouveau
cocktail de fages il y aura toujours des
phages capable de déjouer les défenses
des bactéries vous savez si vous êtes
invités biologique la plus abondante sur
la planète parce que vous avez quelques
trucs pour persister dans
l'environnement
selvam on nous rappelle qu'elle eiffage
ne seront peut-être pas la solution à
toutes les maladies bactériennes
[Musique]
mais pour plusieurs d'entre elles il
reste convaincu du succès de cette
thérapie pour réduire beaucoup
d'antibiotiques encore utilisé en
élevage je vous rappelle que c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'isoler un nouveau
bactériophages que d'isoler un nouvel
antibiotique
c'est peut-être là clé l'espoir c'est
qu'effectivement les bactéries vont
évoluer
c'est clair que les virus et volume en
même temps et c'est pratiquement certain
qu'on voit capable de trouver rapidement
de nouveaux bacs ailleurs
[Musique]
il